[music playing]
HOST: Congratulations,
bladesmiths.
You made it through
to the final round,
but your work is far from over.
Now we're sending
you back to your home
forge to create an iconic
blade from history--
the kora.
[nervous laughter]
HOST (VOICEOVER): The kora
sword originated in Nepal, where
it was wielded for centuries
by a legendary group
of soldiers, the Gurkhas.
The Gurkhas were known for
their fearless military prowess
of weapons-based
martial arts, which
included symbolic weaponry
like the kora sword.
This fearsome sword features
a long, curved blade
that flares outward
at the tip, maximizing
the force of each swing and
making it an ideal weapon
for both slashing and chopping.
Also used in sacrifice,
a skilled kora
wielder could reportedly
cut a sheep in half
with just one swing.
HOST: It must be an
effective, working version
of that deadly weapon.
It must include a spatulated
hook tip, a guard, and pommel.
Josh has definitely
never made a kora before,
and neither have I.
HOST: You will have
five days at your home
forge to complete
this challenge.
At the end of five
days, you will
return to present
your finished koras
to our panel of expert judges.
Only after they've subjected
those weapons to a series
of brutal tests will
they declare one of you
the "Forged in
Fire" champion who
gets that check for $10,000.
Good luck, bladesmiths.
We'll see you in five days.
Good luck.
You too.
It's day one at my
home forge, and I'm
hoping to get accomplished
the rough forging of my blade.
I've never made any
blade this long before,
so it's going to
be an adventure.
Josh has more to lose
because he is a master smith.
I really hope that he
doesn't underestimate
me during this challenge.
I'm going to try to stay
pretty historically accurate.
I'm going to be
forging Damascus,
and having that Damascus
on a large blade
will really be pretty cool.
This is the biggest build
of Damascus I've ever made.
As I'm forging out the Damascus,
I'm realizing it's way too big,
and I can't actually
hold it correctly
because it's too long.
Everything about this big
billet is taking a lot of time--
me swinging it from
the forge to the press
and drawing it out and
waiting for it to heat up.
I'm going to have to
speed things up tomorrow.
Yesterday, got the blade
all forged, the Damascus made.
So today, I hope to
get it all profiled
and successfully heat treated.
And I'd like to grind
a fuller in this blade.
I think in order to beat
this kid, I got to do
some things that he won't.
This groove will take a
little bit of weight out,
but more than anything,
I think it's cool.
Groove looks pretty good.
Today's probably the most
critical day of the five.
Here goes nothing.
If the heat treat
fails, it's a couple
of days worth of lost work.
Seems to be hard.
Generally, you heat
treat and grind
an edge on a sword or
a blade based on what
it's going to be used for.
And I don't know what
it's going to be used.
For that's the problem.
Today, I'm going
to do my heat treat.
Unfortunately, I don't
have a heat treating
oven large enough, so
I'm going to have to do
this in the propane forge.
Yeah, this sword is at least
twice as big as I'm used to.
I would not normally heat
treat something like this.
Hopefully this thing
heats up evenly.
OK, go for the quench.
It's perfectly straight.
It's really hardened.
And now I'm going to sharpen
it, and then I'll do my testing.
Worked pretty good.
Josh better bring his
A-game to beat this.
Good boy.
JOSH: All right, we'll try a
test out here of this edge.
It's day four.
My blade is done.
That thing really
sticks in there.
I don't know what Liam's
blade's looking like right now,
but it's hard to imagine
that he's got anything
going better than mine.
I'm feeling really confident.
The handle-- probably my last
big hurdle on this sword.
Getting ready to put
my handle in the acid
here to etch the Damascus.
Looks pretty cool.
That handle should be
about bulletproof--
screwed and glued.
I don't think there's any
more I could have done.
This is my best.
Win or lose, I created
something that most people
can't, so I'm proud of that.
The Nepalese kora was a blade
that had the distinct inward
curve and the spatula
could flare at the tip,
making it a weapon for
slicing and chopping.
And we'll cut across
these sandbags.
That'll see how sharp
your blades are.
Josh, you're up first.
Are you ready?
I'm ready.
Let's do it.
[music playing]
Josh, great balance.
The blade really wants
to chop and slice.
The recovery of the
blade makes it one that
wants to continue for combat.
One problem I have
here is this handle.
It tends to roll.
But other than
that, it will cut.
Good job, sir.
Thank you.
Liam, you're up next.
Are you ready?
Yeah.
[music playing]
When you said that this was
heavy, you weren't kidding.
This is a chopper.
A little hard to
control on the recoil,
but not enough to
where I can't wield it.
This, sir, will cut.
Great.
Good job.
Next up is a strength test.
Dave?
DAVE: Gentlemen, to test
the strength of your kora,
I'm going to take one
blow into these skulls.
Josh, you're up.
Are you ready?
I'm ready.
DAVE: All right, fantastic.
[music playing]
Nice.
DAVE: Josh, it went right
into the skull, swings
easy, super lightweight,
but like Doug said,
the handle wants
to roll in my hand.
Nonetheless, nicely done.
JOSH: Thank you.
DAVE: All right, moving on.
You ready?
Yeah.
DAVE: OK.
I feel really
confident in my blade.
If Josh's can do it, then
mine will do it as well.
[music playing]
Wow, it's a beast.
It feels really
nice in the hand.
You did a great
job on this handle.
Obviously, we pretty much
took care of that skull.
Now, this thing, once you get
it started, it's going to go.
LIAM: Right.
My only worry is stopping it.
You don't always have
to have a heavy blade
to make a heavy blow, but
it's a beautiful piece.
It's a nice job.
LIAM: Thank you.
Well done.
HOST: Liam, Josh, both of
your weapons are spectacular.
But in this competition, there
can only be one champion,
and that champion is Liam.
Congratulations.
You are the "Forged
in Fire" champion.
Josh, unfortunately, your
blade did not make the cut.
Dave will explain.
DAVE: Josh, we've never seen
two weapons so evenly matched,
and our decision came down to
one incredibly small thing,
and it was the fact that that
handled torqued in Doug's
hand, torqued in mine.
It's an amazing piece of work.
You should be
incredibly proud of it.
I mean, I wish I could own it.
HOST: Josh, please
surrender your weapon.
JOSH (VOICEOVER): I came
here to challenge myself,
and I came here to hopefully
represent bladesmithing well,
and I think I did that.
I'm disappointed in
the judges' decision,
but I'm satisfied with
the kora that I produced.
I'm going home to my kids,
which is where I'm happiest,
so that's where I want to be.
Liam, congratulations.
You are the "Forged
in Fire" champion
and will be receiving
a check for $10,000.
Good job.
You are our youngest
champion so far.
Congratulations.
Great job.
Good job.
LIAM (VOICEOVER):
I just won "Forged
in Fire," which is-- wow.
This is a big feat
for me to accomplish
against a master smith.
I think that all the people
that I went to high school
with-- they'll finally
realize it's not just a hobby.
It's something that I
can really succeed at.
I'm going to use the
$10,000 and just put
it straight into a new shop.
And these are like my
only pair of jeans,
so maybe I'll get
another pair of jeans.